You pay for a transcription subscription here,
credits there, and then your data ends up
on some server in the USA.  Then
I have something better for
you right here.  An app that runs completely free
, locally open source on your
computer, and that's what we're going to take a
closer look at now.  Hello and
welcome.  My name is Daniel, as always,
and today I would like to introduce you to Open
Whisper.  Open Whisper has
2500 GitHubs.  Stars is a super cool
open source app.  The whole thing is based on
the models from OpenAI, that is,
from the Chat GPT developers, who have
extremely good language models.
And if you're now wondering, wait a
minute, why do I need a
transcription app?  The Mac can do that
natively.  Yes, he can, but not
as well and not as quickly.  And as I
said, it's free if you
run it locally on your computer;
the data stays with you, and I've
always used Whisper Flow before.
That's a different app, but it costs $12 a
month.  So why not make the
whole thing [music]
free if it
works well?  Of
course, there is also an option if you
work in the cloud, but then you have to pay for it
.  But of course we don't want that,
and
I'll now show you how to install it locally on your Mac
.  First, we
download the entire program here, and once you
have installed and opened it,
it will look like this
.  You'll probably land on the
homepage; your
transcripts will be here.  Of course, that won't be the case for you
yet.  Then you go
to Settings here, and now comes the
whole hack.  You go to
Transcription here, then to
Local here, and there we have
different models.  We are using
the Whisper model from OpenAI here.  I
took the turbo mode here.  The disadvantage
I've noticed is that the turbo model
is a bit slower on an M2, on my MacBook Air
.  It's not
much, but you can definitely notice it, and that's why
I installed this Small
or Medium version, I think, and
it has really great performance
and also really great quality. That's exactly what
you download,
then it's active, and then you just set
the hotkey, i.e., the key
you want to use to talk.
Here you can set the activation mode
, either by tapping or holding.
And then he listens and
transcribes the whole thing in real
time.  Of course, I'll show you the whole thing
in real life, how it
works.  I'll just open
an arrow here, then hold down the "uh"
key here, and then I'll babble
into the microphone and then
we'll see how fast it
all goes.  Okay, I'm releasing the button now
.  He needs a moment, and
then it's all here.  Okay, and
hold the button down for a few seconds.  Give it a
little bubble.  I'll put the microphone in here and then
we'll see how quickly it all
goes.  Okay, I'll leave the key here, right?
And he transcribed it extremely well.
Of course, you can also turn on
things like intelligence here
.  Then it simply filters
out all the Ös.  Feel free to
play around with this.  This is definitely a
mode worth testing.  There's
also an agent mode.
I haven't
tried that one yet.  You can take a
look at it sometime.
Um, exactly.  You also have
other things here, namely
an audio transcription function
.  They also like to try it out,
inserting audio files and then
transcribing them.  I think that
works quite well too.
The OpenAI models will also be running in the background
.  For example, I installed it in Cloud Code
and
built my own transcription tool there, where
the YouTube videos I
make go directly into and are then
automatically transcribed.  But
as I said, this is also possible with
the app.  You're just bringing something in here
.  If you
want to learn about more tools like these and how you can
also make money with such AI tools,
then
definitely check out my free Print and
Demand course.  I'll include the link
here.  Or watch this video where
I show you how to make
money online with AI coloring books
.  Have lots of fun!  Give the
video a thumbs up and
subscribe, because then
we'll definitely see each other here again.  Until then,
yours truly, Daniel.  Co?